alors là un nouveau rituel dans cette
émission méline mais la carte au hasard
c'est quoi alors c'est tout j'ai même
fait non seulement c'était sait pas
toujours tout vous devez répondre en
imitant bourvil assez génial montre lui
que toutes les cartes ne sont pas les
mêmes voilà nantes est tombé sur les
avons traités avec majeur dans l'univers
thériault bon d'accord
donc je dois vous répondre en imitant
bourvil voilà alors si laurent ruquier
ce que dans la vraie vie vous essayer de
plaire à la ménagère de moins de 50 ans
qui habite au deuxième étage de votre
immeuble
j'aime bien les ménages les petits
jeunes qui sont importants taux
d'audience quand même pas oublier
voilà je fais de mon mieux je joue bien